all right and please be patient as I
start our live stream for our LinkedIn
audience
this will take me a moment
and Welcome to our LinkedIn live
streaming audience our YouTube live
streaming audience and also everyone
who's here on the WebEx app with me my
name is Stuart Creek I'm a marketing
manager here at simply learn
and we are here today
share with you the
Caltech coding boot camp
Caltech coding boot camp is program
from Caltech Center for technology
management education
and it's
powered by simply learn
so we'll be talking about today we would
normally have Mike Ash with us he is not
available we could get um a substitute
from Caltech so I will be
flying solo today I apologize for that
but I will be able to tell you
um pretty much everything you need to
know about the program
and again let's
talk about you during this presentation
we'll talk about full stack coding
careers we'll explain what a Caltech
boot camp is learner outcomes
the enrollment steps if you're
interested in this program and then I
will try to take your questions at the
end
as best as I can
so let's begin with the careers in full
stack coding full stack web development
is why you're all here what you're
interested in and it's really the way
the web gets built today
from
previous forms of
server last server architecture we've
moved into the full stack where
Engineers are expected to understand a
bit about everything from the front end
to the back end to the database
and more and more software
world is migrating off of
old style Enterprise systems or desktop
systems to a software as a service model
uh platform as a service model and
that means more and more
web stack development goes on and
there's more and more demand for people
who can do that
um the systems are notes here are more
than the sum of the front and the back
end the database
Synergy between those components to
create
the apps and
systems that we all know and love Amazon
Facebook
or just examples anything that's a
app on your phone has migrated from
a standalone piece of software that runs
on your phone to
a front end that's integrated with the
web back end
so this is a important and growing field
and only gotten more so the last couple
of years
through the digital transformation of
the pandemic
where more and more of what we do has
moved into the digital domain
um if you're a software developer you
need to understand the full web stack
because
even if you specialize in one aspect of
it you'll want to understand how your
work integrates with the rest of the
stack so it's important to have that
comprehensive knowledge and
they're
so many roles that you can
alt in
full stack development you can be a full
stack developer but you can also choose
to specialize in
the front end the back end database
design
Cloud design you can
find for the ux and UI
you can
decide to want to be a coder that builds
components or you can be a software
architect that Design Systems all of
that becomes open to you when you have
the skills and the tools
that a program like this will give you
and
skills include you know agile for
project management
spring core platform
framework
um
Java and all of its aspects and
durations understanding soap and rest
architectures uh
cloud
servlets in the basics of HTML and CSS
three four
detailed presentation
so
with a complete set of skills you open
up that complete set of job
opportunities and career opportunities
so what I want to ask is a first
question to our audience
is
what has prevented you from
this point and joining
a pudding Boot Camp or other kind of
training program of this type is it
um not being able to find the right one
that'll get you the comprehensive skills
you need
don't feel you'll end up with
practical experience you can show off to
employers
the difficulty of of learning on your
own from pre-recorded videos or is it
just finding the time
so we'll give you another 15 seconds to
answer that if you're on the streaming
services you can put A B C or D
or combinations of that into your
comment chat
close the pole now
apply
so almost two-thirds of you feel that
don't
you haven't found a program that'll give
you the Practical experience the ability
to say I've done this I've used these
skills I I know how to do this and
here's the proof so
um
and then about a third of you in each of
the other
questions here so
let me
share with you
what this program will do and that the
QR code will take you to the program
description page but I'd like you to
stay with us
for a little bit longer while we talk
about
the Caltech cutting boot camp again from
the center for technology and management
education
it's a comprehensive curriculum
industry-aligned learning path meaning
that what you learn is what employers
are looking for in the industry today
with a full set of skills that will
qualify you for the job roles that are
open
it comes with integrated labs and
Hands-On projects for practical
experience all that happens on the same
learning platform which you take your
live virtual classes so you don't have
to have separate systems or separate
tools for that it's all integrated into
the same learning management system and
those on on online live virtual
classrooms
we'll meet uh weekly that's the one part
of the course that you have to make a
set time for
um and then from that
during those sessions you get to
interact directly with your instructors
live
um you get to share questions with the
class
that walk through the exercises and the
techniques and then for all the rest of
the material whether that's videos to
prepare you for your upcoming class
whether that's um
labs and projects that are due by the
next class session
do those anytime during the week 24 7 at
whatever schedule fits your lifestyle so
we say that this takes really about 10
to 15 hours a week of time because
you'll have eight hours of
total live classes each week and then
some homework so
you need to be able to devote that time
to it but if you can devote just that
amount of time
and find that in your schedule you'll be
able to succeed at this program at the
end of it all you're going to have
a certificate from Caltech that
attests to the fact that you've
completed the core courses
with
full marks that you're able to do all of
the things that the core and elective
courses you've taken
taught you
you'll have a git portfolio to show off
projects that you've done which will
include a Capstone project that I'll
describe in a few moments
if you are in a job or an industry or
profession that requires you to provide
continuing education
uh proof to a licensing board or to your
employer Caltech will uh give you up to
17 continuing education units
for this program
and it gives you admission to the
Caltech ctme Circle
to the alumni association for people who
have gone through
the technology and management programs
from Caltech great networking
opportunity for your career going
forward
and you will be recognized at an online
convocation
actually virtual graduation ceremonies
invite friends and family to see as
you're honored for completing your
program
qualifying for your new or improved
career
Caltech
as we all know I I keep wondering why we
don't talk more about the Big Bang
Theory because that's
where everybody knows caltech's name in
popular culture today but it's a 130
year old Institution
it's the home of the NASA jet propulsion
laboratory it's created and has on on
faculty a
large number of Nobel laureates and
consistently ranks in one of the top
five universities in the world it is
not oriented towards undergraduate
educations oriented towards graduate
Education and Research it cranks out
phds and Nobel prizes and um
so there
they are intimately aware of what uh
industry needs and what Cutting Edge of
Technology brings
and that's what the ctme program does so
having that on your curriculum you pay
your your resume is really something
that will stand out
we're very proud to be associated
with Caltech here at simply learn
and to be the vehicle for them
delivering this program
the eligibility of prerequisites for a
program like this are are pretty
straightforward you don't have to have a
programming background
so if you are fresh out of school
you don't need to have
um work experience as a programmer you
don't have to have a programming
background
you do need to have aptitude for it
that's one of the things we evaluate
when you apply but all you really need
is a bachelor's degree in the relevant
domain so it needs to be a technical
domain
it doesn't have to be computer science
necessarily but computer science
engineering mathematics
statistics all those types of
degrees and you must have at least a c
average so
um
if you've got that prerequisite I
encourage you to apply
and
just to get a feel for who's in our
audience today I'd like to ask
this poll in question which is
how much experience do you have and this
would be you know experience in the
workplace doesn't have to be
technical technology coding that type of
thing but just how much experience do
you have in the workplace
get a feel for who's in the audience
today
and we'll give you another 10 seconds
here we go
apologize for staring at the polling
widget
all right and half of our audience are
people who are fairly recent graduates
so less than two years of uh work
experience
um interestingly
about a third of the audience has more
than 10 years of experience and the
interesting thing about this program the
great thing about it is it's actually
suitable for both audiences
what I mean by that is if you are newly
uh graduated looking to start a career
this is a great way to build the
foundation if you are looking to Pivot
into
um all stack coding
from some other domain
this is also a great program for you so
let me move on to
how this program prepares you and
unfortunately again Mike
not here we couldn't get Rick Hefner to
be here to this morning on either but I
will go through basics of how this
program
um
prepares you so I can't do the live tour
but I will explain what the learning
management system does learning
management system to manage your
curriculum you log on to the
LMS and it lists all of the courses that
are in your Caltech cutting boot camp
but it only unlocks the one you're
working on start off with your
trajectory Course once you finish that
it unlocks the first course
object-oriented programming
and each course gets unlocked as you
finish it so it takes you in a
sequence
that's important because that builds
your skills in that sequence and gives
you the foundation for the next course
when you complete the course you're in
so
live virtual classroom is there within
the learning management system it shows
you your calendar it shows you when your
next classes are takes you right into
the classroom where you interact with
the instructor
both on video and
the instructor's paired whiteboard or
programming
environment so you're going right along
with the instructor on
your exercises
going through the techniques step by
step asking your questions live
it allows you to do your tests your Labs
your projects within that same
environment
last course in the sequence is always a
Capstone project Capstone project we'll
talk about a little bit
but that takes all the skills you've
learned in the previous courses puts
them all together into one industry
aligned problem that you need to solve
and then you build the full stack system
that addresses that need
and that becomes a permanent part of
your git portfolio so that you can show
that off
for future employers say this is my
proof that I am a full stack web
developer
like as I mentioned the learning
management system tracks your progress
through the courses unlocks any
certificates you earn
for each course but also for any other
courses that might be offered that have
their own certification and then when
you get through the Capstone project it
unlocks the final certificate
for the entire program that
your graduation
and it concludes includes support that
you need to be able to get through this
program
um on a 24x7 basis so you can always of
course email your instructor if you're
stuck on something but you can turn it
to
24x7 support staff and simply learn who
include people who can answer questions
about the course material or people who
can address any Tech questions about the
learning management system
you also have a community bulletin board
or virtual environment
or your fellow students so you can ask
questions from your peer group get help
that way you have access to all of the
pre-recorded video components as well as
recordings of live classes that you may
have missed so you miss one or two of
those you can always go back and
watching them on video you can it
includes all of the course material that
your instructor is upload including
sample code
other
resource materials so it's a
comprehensive learning environment you
go into it and you can do everything you
need to do and like I said it's
available 24 7 so you can use it on your
schedule
so
that before
this
builds your programs up
your skills step by step
I have a question we'll cover the
questions I'm looking at the chat
briefly just to make sure I'm not
missing anything but we'll cover those
questions when we get to the Q a so
you start off with the orientation then
you go into planning and user interface
design
um then you talk about the back end of
the database
and from that you now have the front-end
backhand now you it
you start looking at API endpoints
communication how do you interface the
system with other systems how do you
communicate uh automated tools
um
and then integration and deployment
that's
a new era relatively new area for
software in that
through devops we no longer have
uh
once every six month big program relief
we now have
essentially continuous integration and
continuous deployment
um and you need to understand how that
works so that applications and and web
environments get updated
in close to real time
so with all of those skills
develop over the first five months of
the program you spend the last three to
four weeks on the Capstone project
and develop the solution for that
industry-based
tool
finally you can take an elective along
the line you can take their Caltech
coding boot camp master classes that are
given by
Caltech ctme instructors you can take
those there are no additional charge
pick them based on your
um
interest
so those are optional for you but again
no additional charge and at the end you
you earn that certificate
we talk about the tools the libraries
the platforms that you'll learn this is
a sampling of them
first get for managing your code
angular
pla
[Music]
front end UI management
um
mongodb is one of the database tools
that we use the the other
things for containerization and
deployment Docker and Jenkins and then
of course the normal
cutting tools CSS HTML JavaScript so
you'll be able to put these and other
skills onto your resume
and be able to confidently State not
only have I been exposed to them but
I've used each one I understand how to
use each one
by the way if you want to look in my
portfolio I can show you how I've done
it so
it's a very valuable tool for your
resume and then back to the Capstone
project the reason I've mentioned it so
many times
um Capstone project is a real life
business scenario
like
you need to build a reservation
system for a multi-restaurant chain
here's a
that might be one of the projects you
could choose
where you now need to develop
both the front end
interface to the user what they might
see on a
desktop or web app that will take them
let them
browse through the different uh
locations for that chain
find the one that's relevant to them
check the reservations
maybe look at the menu
and
then develop you'll also develop the
back-ended database to manage the
reservations as they come in real time
so
this is an end-to-end Business Solution
that you're going to to develop will
take you several weeks to do it your
instructor will be your mentor and meet
with you weekly to keep you on track
make sure you're not getting lost in any
dead ends
um
and then at the end of that process
you've got your final project done that
basically is your final exam for the for
the program
but it's also something that you can
then
I've mentioned before can show that to
employers and say this is how I take a
problem that you might give me and
that's how I would solve it so
it's a very important part of the
program it's really one of the best
parts
so uh talk to you about the people from
Caltech ctme
who are the program uh managers and
director and advisors and they
help
put together the curriculum simply
learns role in that is to provide the
platform
so that
Rick who has over 40 years of experience
and runs this
industry service the Caltech technology
and management education
um
is
the director he oversees the
program
how we work it all the different
programs can run through Caltech
Dave tavaro is especially involved in
this coding boot camp software expert
and
this as I've mentioned the Caltech ctme
program that simply delivers rather than
vice versa so
learner outcomes
the
people who come to this program comes
from a wide variety of backgrounds and
it's not just information technology or
software
but banking a financial service industry
in the
high-tech industry
Aerospace manufacturing
people will come from all different
backgrounds because
today all different types of companies
require full stack web developer so the
companies second their best to go on
these programs
um
by the way
many of the companies will have tuition
reimbursement so that you should ask
your employer if that applies to you
and so you'll be essentially
working with rubbing elbows with in a
virtual world
people from a wide variety of
backgrounds people who can give you
insights into what their companies are
doing
what opportunities are there
and that's part of what we do in terms
of career assistance
so throughout the book cutting boot camp
which is a six-month program and
for the six months following your
certification
simply learn provide you with career
service
career service
uh is available to Learners in the US
this is a U.S oriented program
uh gives you access first to ongoing
education through webinars and career
events
we give you of course the real world
projects that you do during the program
to build up your portfolio we also give
you job assist Services through Talent
Inc
and these
um provide direct assistance with your
job search if that's
part of your plan so
if you're taking a course like this and
with the intention of starting a new
career and finding a job
we support you with that for the six
months following your certification with
access to a exclusive job portal
through talenting called resume rabbit
gives you a way to search for jobs
without revealing your job search to
anybody
um but your employer doesn't find out
that you're you're looking
but it does give you uh access to a
number of exclusive job listings as well
I think the other parts of this are so
important the resume review and rewrite
service
so very important because today's resume
will not go to a human being until it
goes through an automated evaluation
through an artificial intelligence
system so whatever uh hrai
you're applying through
your the employer will make sure that
the
system looks at the resume
and screens candidates that way first
but you need as a job Seeker to
understand how your resume gets
processed how it needs to be formatted
and worded so that the AI bot will
pass it through to a human being
and so it still looks good when it hits
the human beings green or desk because I
don't want it to look
like something that's strictly designed
for me to read you want it also to put
your best foot forward for the human
evaluator who's going to get that and
look at it as a professional document so
the resume rewrite is extremely
important so is the one-on-one interview
crap
going through any type of job search you
have to go through multiple rounds of
interviews summer techno technical to
cover the skills that you bring to the
job
and some are soft skill and cultural
[ __ ]
look at whether you're a team player how
will you take direction do you Mentor
other people all of those types of
skills that uh
are essential to success and the
interview prepping and career coaching
part of the service
will make sure that you're able to
appear as a valuable
candidate
when you do those actual interviews with
people so
these services are very important and as
I mentioned expert webinars simply learn
runs a series of webinars on industry
Trends on
how to care and feed through your career
um
what's new in the world we run
learn it live classes where we go into a
technical topic one of our instructors
then goes it gives an hour-long lesson
in that topic so all of these are
available to you for free
uh and they let you continue your
education on an ongoing basis
so
based on what I've I've given you so far
this this uh thumbnail sketch
just want to get a temperature to see
how many people are interested
in enrolling in the program
so I'll open the poll now
again if you're watching on streaming
you can put yes or no into the chat
leave that open for a couple seconds
and 92 percent of the folks who
answer the question are interested in
enrolling which is great
what I want to do now is share with you
how to do that
so the enrollment process is pretty
straightforward
you contact us at ask us at
simplylearn.net
we'll put that information into the chat
right now
um
and once you do that we will contact you
I said we'll evaluate a couple of things
we'll ask for documentation of your
degree
we'll ask for uh maybe a
brief aptitude test to make sure that
your
interested in and capable of learning
programming Concepts
that said you don't have to bring that
with you from your background but we do
want to make sure that you're able to
pick those things up so that brief
evaluation will make sure that you have
the aptitude the desire and the skills
to succeed
and then you'll get an admission offer
so once you get the admission offer
you can join the program now
the program schedule for the next cohort
is November 3rd
uh January
23rd is when the
classes start
and
the cost of the program is eight
thousand dollars
which you can Finance with interest
refinancing as low as 704 a month as I
mentioned before
if
your employer has tuition reimbursement
they may pick up the cost of the program
all over part
and so you need to ask that question if
this is something that is full in your
job and if your employer will cover that
either by paying in advance or by
reimbursing you after you complete the
program successfully so Works different
ways for different people
um again not part of what we offer as a
service but if your employer offers that
that's really a valuable benefit
so again I encourage you to look in the
chat just put the ask us at
simplylearn.net
email that address there if you're
watching streaming to email for us ask
us at simplylearn.net
and this point I would like to answer
some of your questions so what I'm going
to do now is I'm going to
stop sharing my screen so that we don't
stare at this uh slide for the whole
time you can instead stare at me
I'm going to look here
could you please go back to this first
slide where it says what language you
need to cover for coding so uh
um
this
program is basically going to cover
um
the mean stack I believe and we're
talking about
angular Java mongodb
it turns out that you can deal with
many different uh
versions or several different versions
at least of the of the
full stack
depending on what the different
components are for the front end
back-end database but the skills are
transferable
so
um
for example we're using angular here
instead of react
but that was a choice that we made based
on
the ability
um to get the concepts across real quick
so
um
it's you wouldn't Focus necessarily on
the programming languages but rather on
the concepts of the different elements
of the stack Seth asks what the tuition
fee is and that I think we put that
which is uh eight thousand dollars so
um let me look again here
got a different
place for questions
and hold on a second
so if you have other questions please
get them in
I will try to take them right now
and we're looking at the Sydney's
question what is the difference between
this program and the devops program
so yes we do offer Caltech ctme offers a
uh devops
certification program
and the devops program really focuses on
the
deployment end of cycle so whereas full
stack development program looks at
building an application
the
devops program says okay if people are
building applications in my organization
how do I support the process of
uh
integrating them testing them
deploying them out how can I
automate that process using devops life
cycle so
it's a different set of skills that are
focused on getting applications into the
world
um
under the devops framework so
it qualifies you to be a devops engineer
may not qualify you necessarily to be
the developer of the system that's being
deployed but it gives you an essential
and very well-demanded set of skills for
deploying software so another program
that you can look at if you're
interested in devops
um
looking at a couple of chat questions
here
so why do we learn about one stack
versus the other and
it's a question of
being able to take you through a
particular
uh
full set of
skills
get you from
front end back end database
in the six months
qualify you to do that Capstone project
so rather than
looking at a variety of different
fact models
we go to
um
just that the one Exemplar which is
in stock so
Excuse me while I'm taking the note here
[Music]
um
but again the skills are transferable if
you understand how to do
full stack programming under one stack
model
then you can easily learn how to swap in
different components different levels
in order to work under a different stack
so
that's the reason we had to pick
basically we had to pick one
it turns out that this one is uh
as easy as any to teach maybe easier
uh
Elliot asks questions is it possible to
land a Java job if I only have skill in
JavaScript and node.js some jobs will
ask for that some jobs
will ask for more skills but they will
be you'll be able to learn those when
you get those but in this particular
case if you go through this program you
will be learning
um a full spectrum of java skills so
that you won't be
just stuck in one small aspect of it but
you'll have the ability to to work
across and use the different
tools and libraries
that come with it um
and
that's so that you'll be able to do the
uh
development at every level of the stack
so
let me
that down
and
let me check
Matthew asked a good question who are
the instructors for the program
so the inspectors for our programs are
all taken from industry these are people
uh who
work as
full stack developers in industry
um
they have experience in using the skills
that they're teaching
and
the for this program they all happen to
be us-based
so um
should not be any language issues for
you but it uh
they're all very confident folks who and
again part of the program is also the
people who
in Caltech ctme who provide the master
classes as well so it's a
very strong team of instructors
advisors
that deliver this program to you
just checking it out
probably also asked what's the
difference between devops and automation
courses so
um
devops is uh
form of automation for deployment or
software and then there's other
automation courses that have to do with
uh automating business processes or
automating software testing and that
type of thing so there's a lot of
different um
meanings to automation of which devops
is one
again you will learn some of the the
needed devops tools and skills during
this coding Workshop boot camp
three
uh success if there are any scholarships
available
uh we don't offer
scholarships for this program we do
offer the financing option
also check with your employer for
reimbursement
uh and does your certification recognize
Canadian immigration
um
I am not sure how to answer that
question I would ask you to you know ask
us at simplylearn.net
I'm not sure if you mean
um does this help qualify you to immigr
to apply for immigration into Canada
or is it available to people who are in
Canada who want to take the course
for the latter yes you can take the
question Canada
um we
may not be able to uh
provide you with the same set of
proof support skills
Services as a Canadian citizen but
if that's something that you're you're
interested in
apologize for taking notes Here
and then I think we're going to uh
take a look
is there a discount for people that have
gone through other ctme programs
um
I am not aware of one but that is a good
question and I would ask that of the uh
people ask us at simplylearn.net because
they will be able to address what uh
discounts are available for this program
and
we've got another great question
so let me
so Jan asks I am 75 years old can I do
this
and
given the rest of your background here
you say you uh
passed calculus in college with the
straight A's uh you have a doctor of
jurisprudence degree
although your beginner in programming
uh I have to say yes absolutely
um
there is no age limit
upper age limit on this program
you do have to have a bachelor's degree
so that means you probably have an a
lower age limit
most people or at least 1920 when they
graduate
um
but
you there's no upper age limit and if
you're interested in the material and
you have the time to devote to it
really want to devote the effort to it
again it's 10 to 15 hours a week of
concentrated effort
but definitely something that that
will work for you
and
again if you're qualified as a full
stack web developer
and you can demonstrate that you do the
work and you know the material and you
have the skills
um there's a huge demand for people so
this could be again a second career for
you
um moving from law into programming I
might also point out that Dr Jerry
pictures Prudence you have
very deep domain knowledge of legal
industry which means that
if you did a program like this you would
have
huge value to any company that law firm
that wants to develop systems or
Consultants to law firms or software
development companies that develop
systems for law firms
these people would be very eager to have
somebody like you who understands the
business purpose of the system as well
as the technology of this so that's a
General piece of advice to anybody who's
looking to come into this from another
domain what you know about another
industry or another type of job
kind of work
adds value
because that means that you know how
these tools can be applied in the real
world so
and the last question is from akshat who
says how do you initiate the application
process oxshot that's very
straightforward you just email us at
simplylearn.net
and we will get the ball rolling for you
so with that I'm going to conclude
q a and these are really great questions
so thank you all for
defending them
um
and
I'm going to ask a final question from
the audience
close out the webinar
so for those of you who said you are
interested in
enrolling in the program
how soon would you like to start
something that you'd like to start with
that next cohort where the introduction
is early November
classes start in January or something
that you want to do further down the
road so let me open the poll
I'll leave that open for another 15
seconds or so
again our streaming audience you can go
ahead and put that in the chat comments
all right
uh about 40 of the audience are
interested in joining this uh program
immediately
uh there's another 40 who are looking to
do it out sometime in the future again
we always say if this is something
that's going to uh improve your life
improve your career
impact you in a positive way
consider doing it sooner than later but
again
based on whatever your your
uh life
requirements are and your personal uh
career goals we'll be here for you
whenever you decide to get involved but
for the 40 who want to start right away
please email ask us at simplylearn.net
um and
we will be glad to get you started we'll
also be sending a follow-up email out to
the people who are here on our
live webinar and WebEx if you've
registered but uh if you are watching on
the streaming Channel
um
want to get follow-up information do
contact us at ask us at simplylearn.net
and with that I want to thank everybody
for being here today again my apologies
for not having
um
my colleagues from Caltech here with us
to to give their perspective on the
program
but um
I I can't please reach out to us if you
want any more information and
we can also point you to other recorded
instances this webinar so that you can
hear from
Mike Ash and other people and we'll be
really glad to have you as part of the
Caltech and simply learn learning
community so thank you all for being
here and that concludes our webinar for
today